now to our coronavirus coverage here are
the latest numbers our state positivity
rate
slightly below 7 percent nearly 400 new
cases added yesterday bringing the total
to more than 295 thousand since the
pandemic began as you see also
15 more deaths here are the numbers
specific to clark county where most of
the cases and most of the population is
as you know
you can see 312 of the new cases are
here and all 15 deaths
here in southern nevada the recovery
rate here in clark county
and almost 96 percent the city of
henderson
is opening a new vaccination site for
the coronavirus starting next
tuesday it'll be over at the heritage
park senior facility near lake mead and
boulder highway
the site will be open to all nevadans
who are currently eligible to get the
vaccine
500 vaccinations will be given out but
it's by appointment only
the site will be open for the first
doses march 9th through the 12th and you
can make an appointment at the link
from the city of henderson it is on your
screen city of henderson.com
covid mateen